[Applause]
we've all been with someone that maybe
you're not the proudest of there's also
those images online but maybe or maybe
you didn't find something nice about
don't [ __ ] look at me right now and
tell me that you don't understand what
I'm saying anyway we're gonna react to
some regrettable porn door
doorknob
lady coming out of the doorknob
I'm doorknob there that's my womb well
I'm clearly a fine and healthy woman
aren't I
as you can see I've got all the parts I
need to make babies how can you find a
[ __ ] doorknob sexually oh my god
apparently it's a huge thing in Japan
what the [ __ ] is this
stop stop this at once [ __ ] awesome
giraffe oh my god no this is too much I
can't what the [ __ ] hell I am being
[ __ ] by my own [ __ ] oh she is making
so she's animating her vagina don't
don't do that girls don't do that and
what do you want from me isn't that
obvious
now strip now what the [ __ ] is that a
turtle no don't
no no no don't turtle
oh my god
nope so there you go we share this
moment together now you can say that
you've seen some regretable porn with
Peter Pine I will see you and and
tomorrow or something I make a video
every [ __ ] day alright stay awesome
[Music]